hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the best pocket camera ever made
thanks for watching no but this is a bit
of a secret weapon because first of all
i use this a lot but then i never really
talked to you guys about it so i
realized i figured i should probably
tell you guys a lot more about this
particular device right here uh i've
used footage from it in a couple of
mkbhd videos i take like all of my
instagram photos on it now i bring it
anywhere i go and i have an open pocket
so this is the sony rx100 mark ii now i
know a lot of you guys immediately go to
the description and check out the price
and when you guys see the price of this
you're probably going to first say
no no i really don't want that but
i urge you to watch this video first
and then tell me what you think the
rx100 mark ii is basically a refined
masterpiece at this point it ticks all
the boxes and it makes some improvements
over the original already legendary
rx100 mark 1. everything that can be
good about a pocket camera is good about
this camera so there are already about a
million reviews of the original rx100
out there on the internet but here's the
gist of what you need to know that makes
this camera so good first of all first
and foremost is the 20 megapixel giant
one-inch sensor they put in this thing
that is bigger and more sensitive than
any other camera that fits in your
pocket by a lot with this bigger sensor
you get better low light performance a
shallower depth of field and basically
overall better image quality second is
the super fast carl zeiss lens that's f
1.8 at its widest focal length it's so
that's pretty darn fast it's 3.6 times
optical zoom and it also has optical
image stabilization that works really
well there's also a pop-up flash that
can be articulated and used to bounce
light off the ceiling instead of
blinding your subject every time it also
has a three inch super bright
articulating live view lcd that's
viewable indoors and outdoors and can
help you get your shots at pretty much
any angle thanks to that new
articulating hinge it has just about
every software feature and mode you
could possibly think of anywhere from
full manual control over everything and
raw or jpeg photos to the full auto on
all the creative modes and even built-in
hdr it has wi-fi nfc a hot shoe it has a
smooth turning ring around the lens that
can be programmed to change focus or
aperture or really anything you want it
takes rechargeable batteries that last a
long time and sd cards up to 128
gigabytes right now and the build
quality all around the outside is all
metal so this thing is built like a tank
and it can be tossed into bags and
traveled with all the time the controls
are well built too they're well
organized and easy to learn and they're
pretty clicky and responsive when in use
and on top of all of that the images and
video that come out of this camera are
stunning they are really good so even if
you think this camera is the ugliest
thing in the world you can't deny the
crystal clear image quality colors are
very accurate photos are tack sharp
dynamic range is impressive and
basically what i'm trying to say here is
this blows every other pocket camera out
of the water in this department auto
focus while you're taking photos is
super fast very snappy sharp and
accurate and it also has continuous auto
focus during video recording at 1080p
which is also constantly very fast and
accurate now i don't know about you but
with a lineup like this there's hardly
any reason to consider any other pocket
camera over this one at this price point
so if you guys remember i did videos
from ces in january in the beginning of
this year uh where i did some coverage
of an nvidia event a huawei device uh
sony device and at the end i did a huge
nine minute wrap-up of all of the
highlights of ces yet 99 of that footage
from those videos came from this you can
actually cut between dslr footage and
rx100 footage in a single youtube video
and most people for the most part will
not be able to tell the difference
especially because like we said the
awesome optics the great image quality
and the shallow depth of field thanks to
the fast lens and the big sensor it
gives it that sort of dslr like filmic
look when you're taking videos with it
and on top of all of that this is what
it's like to hold a dslr while taking
video while this is what it's like to
hold a pocket camera while taking
free hand this camera could also be
considered maybe the perfect vlogging
camera because a lot of the vlogging
cameras you already see on youtube are
compact and have to take great quality
video in a tiny package this is exactly
that this is probably even more compact
than a lot of the other youtube cameras
out there and it takes much better video
quality at arm's length now i don't
happen to do this style video all that
often but if you do like i did at ces
then you'll find that delivers well
pretty much awesome quality and it's
much much easier to do this kind of
style with this
than with a dslr so what are the main
differences between the mark ii and the
mark one you may ask well the mark ii
here has wi-fi nfc a hot shoe on the top
and an articulating lcd screen on the
back if you can live without these four
features then might i suggest saving a
little bit of money and getting the
still god-like rx100 mark one and saving
yourself quite a bit of money but i
actually really love having the mark ii
for that wi-fi plus nfc capability which
makes it brilliant for smartphone
control so overall the rx100 and rx100
mark ii clearly
an incredible camera just a really
really great buy for anyone and i would
argue that this could be the full-time
only camera for a lot of youtubers out
there now i see a lot of youtubers go
out and buy a dslrs which is sort of a
larger more unwieldy body for that
cinematic look the shallow depth of
field and the quality that you get but
then they never take advantage of the
interchangeable lenses that you're
supposed to use with a dslr they'll use
the same lens all the time and i would
argue that this is a better buy because
this gets you the same quality the same
image style and it's smaller it's
cheaper and it's just significantly
easier to shoot with like i said you can
get that optical image stabilization is
built in so you don't have to worry
about getting a lens with that you can
use it with one hand and check your
phone at the same time you can vlog with
it it's so much more versatile than a
dslr and it fits in your pocket and you
can take the quality anywhere it's a
great camera so now you can check the
price i know you probably have it in a
new tab anyway but honestly if i was
still giving ratings like numerical
values for devices like this this would
probably be one of those rare 10 out of
10's that just doesn't have any real
flaws to hold it back it's arguably the
perfect camera
but either way thank you for watching
this video and a lot more mkbhd videos
are to come because these are like the
two most exciting months of tech
september october uh so i'm really
excited thumbs up for that and most
importantly let me know if you guys want
to see more like device like smaller
device reviews like this i i haven't
reviewed this camera the one i'm
shooting this on right now i have my
amazon gear list in the description of
every video and a lot of the stuff on
that list i have not reviewed yet so let
me know if there are things on that list
that you want to see me make a video
about like i said thanks for watching
and i will talk to you guys in the next
video peace
you